Jarrid it's Ross Tucker man it's good to
talk with you where are you right now
hey Ross how's it going I'm actually in
my hotel room in Jacksonville right now
we'll be here for the week until I think
believe Thursday night we'll fly out to
London so you're just hanging in
Jacksonville for the next four days
that's right that's right
so what do you guys like did you bring
enough clothes you guys all pack like a
ton of stuff yeah no we actually did the
trip last year we stayed in London
instead we went from Detroit to London
so we kind of have a little bit of
experience doing this some of the guys
on the team and so yeah you pakka's
tackled an extra bag and I sent it out
here for us and so yeah we got a bunch
of clothes and all that stuff's good to
go what do you think about staying in
Jacksonville for four days and then
going versus just going straight out to
London you know I'm actually happy we
did it this way you know it takes a
little bit you know I guess the travel
immediately after the game can be tough
you know that flights pretty long
especially last year from Detroit was a
little bit longer than it will be this
year but I'm happy we're staying out
here you know it's nice weather
weather's great Suns always out and we
get to practice out here and then head
out to London and once once we know we
head out there we know it's time to play
time with Jared golf the quarterback of
the Rams here on the damn Patrick so
Jared a couple weeks ago I was out in
London I called the the Ravens Jags game
it is so impressive how much they love
football over I know I don't think
people really realize what was your big
takeaway your big experience last year
what did you think of it yeah I agree I
think it's cool to see how crazy they
are about the sport and you know it's
funny you go to the games and it's it's
just like if there was a soccer game out
here I would think you know you wear
whatever soccer jersey you have they
wear whatever football jersey they have
which is pretty cool to see you know who
they're fans of and all that and it's
fun to get over there and meet those
fans and see how you know excited there
are you a trade jersey guy after the
game like the soccer guys and somebody
NFL guys no not typically if it's one of
my good friends or somebody I've known
for a while sure but you know not
typically I always wondered - like what
are the guys do with all those jerseys
yeah you frame him I've got some friend
of my house but I didn't I didn't raid
them after the game you know I'll just
text my buddies I played in college with
or something hate you know send me a
jersey frame and put him in your house
and you know he stole your buddy's
jerseys up on my wall it's pretty cool
yeah you know it's funny I think Jarrod
cuz I play for so many teams that the
only Jersey I got framed was from a Matt
Smith he gave it to us as a Christmas
gift I ended up selling that because I
didn't want to put that up in my house
who do you have it you're in yours oh
man all my guys from Cal you know Bryce
drags Chris Harper Darius pal Maurice
Harris Stephen Anderson all those guys
play with that Cal that are now in the
league currently that's awesome okay so
we're talking with Jared golf he's the
quarterback of the Rams you're going
over to London what did you do last year
in London and will you have time to do
anything this year like did you any of
the the sightseeing or tourist stuff
yeah we last year we went out we'll
probably not much time this year may
have Friday and maybe but last year went
down to the city and you know I took the
train only out there and I was cool and
then walked around saw a Big Ben saw the
London Eye you know I mean you're just
walking around you see a bunch of
historical things it was fun I was cool
you only went to the big castle and the
palace it was fun so last year it did
not go well for you and the team when
you were starting how much better is it
in the experience just being around a
winning team just during the work week I
mean how much more enjoyable is it this
everybody's body language and mannerisms
you know it's definitely more fun
anytime you're winning it's a lot of fun
and that's the whole reason we play the
game is to win and you know it's
especially on a trip like this when we
get this win yesterday and be able to
stay in Jacksonville it's definitely
more enjoyable but uh you know we're
trying to take it one game at a time
we're happy with what we've done so far
were four and two but it's early on the
season not even halfway through and you
know we got a lot of work to do in your
mind Jared I know you've been asked this
a bunch but what's the biggest
difference between this year and last
year for you personally I think I've
just grown up a bit more mature and
understand the game more you know just
understand and you know what's going on
and understanding defenses understanding
what we're doing on offense more and
more and just continue to grow and learn
and becoming a better player what about
as a team I mean obviously your
performance has been a big part of it
but in terms of the team being you know
so much better than you guys were last
year you know how much of that's mcveigh
how much that some of the other guys
they brought in like Whitworth and woods
you know where do you put most of the
credit for what you guys have done so
far yeah you know I think it's just a
lot of different things but I think one
thing like you talked about you look at
is the veteran leadership we've added
with with Whitworth and John Sullivan
and Connor Barwon and and some of those
older guys even Roberts into his fifth
year now and so yeah some of those older
guys that we've added that have become
leaders of this team and guys that you
can look to the guys have done it the
right way before guys that have been on
their playoff teams and good teams in
the past and you can look to them for
the way that way to go about your
business and the way to handle things I
think it's been awesome to you know get
a chance to play with them I mean you're
still a really young guy is it weird to
you at all that you've got teammates
that are like married and have two three
kids because I remember my rookie year I
was like blown away by that it's just I
mean like they're grown men yeah
definitely eyeballs about it sometimes
you know tell them tell my old they are
and whatnot you know it's funny but I
know it's a you get used to it I mean
you know it's it's weird at first it
still is kind of weird you know when
their kids come running through the
locker room and whatnot but you know
it's fun and I enjoy it and you know
like to give him a hard time about it
sometimes talking with Jared Golf from
the Rams just going back to uniform
thing real quick
whether it's your buddies or whoever
you guys are switching jerseys have you
been getting a lot of flack for some of
the like the color combos that you guys
have done like the difference between
your helmet your sleeves and stuff yeah
no we definitely have I actually think
they look kind of cool I don't I just
really don't think they look weird
especially yesterday with the with the
white pants I think it's kind of cool I
thought last week was it last week that
you were like the old-school Rams that
was yeah the throwback oh man yeah I
think those are pretty I'd like to see
also you do the the the what you did
last week but white instead of yellow or
gold or whatever it's called yeah yeah
yeah like that like the way back in the
day like the Merlin Olsen that robe and
the Andy Reid punt pass and kick thing
yes
hey Polly wants to know how are you on
DP shirts he wants to make sure that
you're gonna fly the colors over in
London I need so I need some you Peter
them we could probably organize a trail
I tell you I got Shawn wearing them
every day and I feel left out
well well Jared we sent a box to Sean
and I have the feeling didn't share any
with you guys zero he wears them every
day though I'm not kidding you seven
days a week four hours of five five over
seven days that is awesome duty I
actually don't like this I'm so tired by
the way I told him I was going to yes he
says he'll show him we said hello but to
try to get out of my lane Sean's trying
to angle to be like the ex-player fill
in when he's done we don't need to Sean
we got that covered yeah Paulie go ahead
Jared can we trade on behalf of Dan
could we trade a game-used autographed
next winders e for a box of shirts that
go right to you not to Mannion done deal
love it beautiful easy hey last question
Jared we were talking about movies
somehow because that's what always
happens what's your favorite sports
movie
favorite sports movie ooh mmm well I
think the sandlots an easy answer
that's definitely up there you were you
were like however you and that came out
like really no idea what year to come
out how old are you
I'm just turned 23 two days ago
oh my gosh happy birthday man thank you
23
those were the days Sam I feel really
old now 23 is no longer a child I'm a
grown man
yeah no 23 it's like all right son
you're in your mid-20s what are you do
with your life exactly Sam Locke came
out in 93 when were you born turd
94 oh gosh I'm talking to an NFL
quarterback it was born after sitting
out oh man
Jerry there's probably so much you don't
know about movies and good shows and
stuff there's so much we could teach you
know for sure for sure yeah I don't
I see this is a conversation I was Sean
actually a lot Sean's a big movie guy
really getting the movies that much you
know he loves movie so he talked about
all the time he's always giving me
suggestions of what the watching that
what nah he's really good with that
stuff but you know I'm not a huge movie
guy but I could use some more I'm still
still watching some nice Jarrod
appreciate the time man keep it rolling
it's fun that you guys are playing as
well as you are have fun in Jacksonville
in London all right thank you guys I
appreciate it
all right there he is Jerry golf
starting quarterback of the four and to
LA Rams the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience